next question
okay he's he's talking about the tim
ferriss the video yeah that was the
extension of your tim ferriss
yeah yeah popular one about you talking
about martial arts or martial arts what
are the best martial arts right
if you haven't seen them you can look it
up um so
he says with respect to the above
mentioned video
about your views on real martial arts i
have one quick question
you said that you came to your
conclusion based on a sparring match
between yourself and one of your fellow
navy seals
was the match between yourself and the
traditional martial
arts with 20 years experience a friendly
sparring match typical in training
where he was pulling his punches and
strut in strikes or was he attacking you
with full force
from my observation jiu jitsu guys
collect some head shots while going in
for takedown
and if a traditional karateka karate
practitioner
doesn't hold back would this have some
devastating effects
in the long run similar to what pro
football's players experience
i would love to get your take on this
someone who has real
world experience okay so
first of all i didn't come to a
conclusion
based on that one event i mean that
event
influenced my thoughts today but even
right now i don't have a conclusion
someone could show me something today
it's possible that i go wow that worked
really well i never thought of that and
that's
new that now trumps everything else it
could happen
not likely though uh my mind is still
open but that's not likely i've seen a
lot now in that
particular scenario he was usually he
wasn't using a striking art a
traditional striking art he was using a
traditional grappling
art actually aikido and so
he he was grappling with me he wasn't
throwing punches at me
but it doesn't matter because i have
sparred
and or fought with plenty of people over
the years
that were absolutely trying to knock me
out no doubt about it
and the fact of the matter is it doesn't
work
um even where this guy
above like for instance this guy in the
question he says
if a traditional karate practitioner
doesn't hold back it would have the same
devastating effect in the long run
similar to what pro football players
experience
that statement actually defeats itself
because
if you watch a football game those guys
get hit in the head
100 times during a football game and how
often do they get actually knocked
unconscious
not very often if you multiply whatever
10 players per side that are actually
banging heads times however he plays you
know you're talking about
thousand well you know probably more
than a thousand
head on head contacts in a football game
and there might be
one knockout in a game sometimes there's
no knockouts yeah typically none no
yeah okay so the fact of the matter is
hitting someone in the head is not a
guaranteed knockout by any stretch of
the imagination in fact it rarely occurs
it actually rarely occurs in boxing
where two guys are trained to do that
so it's hard to knock somebody out and
it's the same thing
in if you watch ufc especially the early
ufcs
this was proven over and over again that
yeah the the grappler is going to take
some hits on the way in
but they're going to get in and they're
going to take the person down
and of of course do you have a puncher's
chance
of course you do there's a very small
chance that when you shoot in on
somebody they time a knee or they time a
punch and it happens to hit you right in
the spot that knocks you out
it does happen it happens in ufc
occasionally if you look at the number
of takedowns
to the number of knockouts that happen
while the takedown is going on it's not
a big number
at all yes correct so you don't want to
rely on that as your formation of
self-defense
correct at all now when things evolved
eventually to where the strikers were
wrestlers too and you got guys like
chuck and you got tito and you got randy
where
it wasn't their striking that was
preventing the takedown it was because
they were bad ass wrestlers
that's what was stopping the takedown it
had nothing to do with the way they
punched yeah so
you really can't count
on striking to stop a grappler that is
not
a good plan right to say hey i'm going
to get so good at striking that i'm
going to stop a grappler that is not a
good
plan what you have to do is learn to
grapple you have to learn to wrestle you
have to learn jiu jitsu
and and the opposite side of that is you
can't
count on grappling to take down a
striker because
that person might know how to wrestle
yeah and therefore you need to know how
to strike
so it goes back to what i say all the
time you gotta know how to graph a gap
not a strike
right yeah and if he's um he's talking
he says a traditional
karate practitioner traditional so and
i'm assuming
the the only understanding i have this
of traditional is he doesn't do karate
and jiu-jitsu he's not a mixed martial
artist he just knows karate so
from what i've lost on the ground yes
and i've taken karate before
and there was no takedown defense there
was no takedowns
there was no functioning in any capacity
on the ground and so
yeah and how you say like okay over the
long term okay you're gonna have
head trauma and lasting damage if you
take
sustained yeah head trauma repetitive
competitive over the years really
but we're worried about the next 42
seconds of a fight that's about to
happen not the next three decades of my
life where you can see me break down
because i took some head trauma
exactly right so you'd have to get let's
say that for the example of this
question
that your experience with this guy he
was a karate guy
and he was going full speed and he
didn't knock you out we'll just
assume that he didn't knock you out you
would have to go through i'm just going
to restate that that is a very safe
assumption
to assume that the karate guy was not
able to knock me out
that i was able to come in you know
stand there good get it a good distance
fake him with my hands
touch his face a couple times he throws
a big punch i do a double leg takedown
he's on his back it's game over
yeah and by the way go watch any youtube
video
of you know jiu-jitsu versus whatever
right and it's the same outcome every
single time uh
you know occasionally there'll be one
with a lot of hits because it's the
it's the chance knockout or the chance
of something else happen yeah
but 99 of the time
yeah it's double leg take down slam on
the ground game over
yeah sorry look at uh
who did randy kutcher fight that pro
boxer tony
james tony oh yeah yeah yeah i mean was
it was that exactly here's
a a world-class boxer professional boxer
right what did randy do
got inside took him down game over oh
why did he knock him out because you
can't
right you can't just you can't just
knock people out
yeah fully and and that's not to mention
and
i mean i'm gonna mention it but that it
is not to mention that
especially if you if you practice the
the more
self-defense like if it's heavily
self-defense oriented jiu-jitsu
one of the first things you learn is
distance management one of the first
things you learn
it's like you almost can't get past that
element
of it so you will take hits of course
maybe you'll take it to the top of your
head
shoulders or whatever but yeah
significant strikes to anything to
warrant
how it's stated here in the question um
long-term
term damage compared to football players
you were back to your situation
you going with this guy let's say he did
go full speed you would have to
do probably 10 to 15 bouts of that every
single day
for a long time yeah for you to have any
sustained damage and then
so maybe if this guy's taking the
long-term strategic view that he's gonna
continue to spar me and hit me in the
head until i'm
70 years old maybe hugolystic disease
and maybe i'm saying
maybe so because if he's a traditional
guy he doesn't know how to take
manage the takedown so knowing how to
manage the takedown
makes your strikes more effective you
don't have that your strikes are not
effective so okay you take one hit
let's say let's say you take five hits
right
you controlling the fight as much as jiu
jitsu does even if you're not that high
level versus a guy who doesn't know
jiu-jitsu
way outweighs this grossly to the point
that
these things are aside from the
puncher's chance
ineffective and i think ufc one two
three
you know as before people start to get
hit to the whole jiu jitsu thing
but before people knew jiu jitsu they
just knew their other stuff that was the
testing ground that was the whole reason
ufc was invented by the way yeah and
that's why those first ufcs are awesome
yeah you you get to see these 250 you
know bare knuckle
kick boxer guy strong you know go in
there
with real quote-unquote real fighting
experience against a
way smaller grappler jiu jitsu guy and
lose
in fact this is to go one step further
if you watch ufc
2 pat smith who's he was one of my
favorite guys by the way when i was
watching he's a kickboxer he was badass
guy 210
solid wrecking guys makes it to the
finals against hoist gracie
and royce gracie didn't tap him out or
he tapped him out but now with the
submission hold he tapped him due to
strikes
so a grappler guy found it out like you
know
a striker guy um no submissions it was
all punches it was
nowadays no one would ever tap to that
now but i'm just saying yeah
only because they know if you don't know
you just think you're dead
yeah yeah one guy like i said before one
guy tapped because he was claustrophobic
he just got mounted
but nonetheless um yeah you
it's it's hard to to really reconcile
really what this question i don't know
if it's implying anything
well it's definitely implying that this
guy that i was going against was like
holding back
right and that might you know hold a
different tale
but yeah i've been against countless
literally countless of guys have sparred
against me trying to knock me out
whether they're traditional martial
artists whether they're just countless
guys
yeah and it's hard to knock somebody out
yeah and i don't i don't know who asked
the question of course i'm not gonna you
know hate on the question or nothing
like that
but speaking from experience this sounds
like the exact question
that inexperienced people have you know
people who are well
no this is coming most likely from
somebody that's been heavily involved in
traditional martial arts and has been
told that hey don't worry about somebody
trying to take you down because if you
just hit them here and here they'll fall
and you'll win
that's exactly what i'm talking about
that's not that's not good that's sort
of why i put this in here you know just
to make sure that
um that they realize that hey you
shouldn't
you should actually pay attention to
what else is going on in the world
instead of
staying in like hey just this one little
traditional martial art yeah and it's
the same thing with
if you're just doing jiu jitsu and we're
gonna i got this in here later there's
another question about this but
i mean i i don't tell people just train
jiu jitsu
i tell them train jiu jitsu change
wrestling train boxing chain muay thai
and you know what when you get done with
all that and you have a good base train
krav maga and then you
you know what do realistic situations by
the way you should learn how to shoot a
gun and by the way you should be in good
shape
do everything yeah yeah
agreed one answer is not the answer yeah
t-shirt
next question every time we say
something like that
like one answer is not the answer which
i must admit sounds pretty cool
that's pretty dope yeah but we'll get
everyone's gonna say
put that on a t-shirt and then i have to
refer to echo and see if he's gonna put
it on a t-shirt
you know we'll see how that works out